what advice do you have to young folks
that are facing this future
almost always it's some version of
start right away and that applies in so
many different ways so if you're
thinking about oftentimes the context is
people want to do what I do and I always
say Do not sit around for a year
thinking about lighting
this is how you never do anything and I
dozens of people who I felt obligated to
talk to on the phone because of a
personal connection I go through all the
advice and I can tell
they're not going to do it they just
they're it's already sounding too
complicated and so instead they'll sort
of say well I gotta get the right
Lighting in the right room and the best
thing you can do no matter what you're
doing is just start right away